[Music]  both feet all the way into the laughs  good warming policy parted for me we  looked at two for one skids to a stop  fires on scores  [Applause]  [Music]  without hacks say something these shots  are bad but who's going to get those  buckets seven straight who's going to  get those buckets there's a steel  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  it's seven straight lies at the Myles  Turner piss go to work chat  well he closed out that first hafnia on  a sick soul run tomato run by that  ravine their guards are in there trying  to rebound  we'll be deep corner three exact hit  that shot Neal but again there's no  movement mike has the Bulls last 11  points and he goes for the last 13 14  the oxen and he's the one guy they can  get his shot and say the Myles Turner  without having to bonus in the game you  might as well just give the ball was  that the power back to Zach left to play  Indiana timeout 64 60 Indiana  [Music]